If you don't believe the Bible and know
we're living in the last days, you're
not paying attention.
>> I am announcing this government will
make a new free of charge digital ID
mandatory for the right to work by the
end of this Parliament. We spell that
out. You will not be able to work in the
United Kingdom if you do not have
digital ID.
It's as simple as that because decent,
pragmatic, fair-minded people, they want
us to tackle the issues that they see
around them. For too many years, it's
been too easy for people to come here,
slip into the shadow economy, and remain
here illegally. But the simple fact that
every nation needs to have control over
its borders. We do need to know who is
in our country.
>> This is really making me think of
Revelation 13 when it says no man may
buy or sell unless he has the mark. Now,
don't get me wrong. I don't think
digital ID is the mark of the beast, but
it will be used to enforce the mark of
the beast. Digital currency, social
credit, digital ID, all these things
will be used to enforce you to worship
the way that the beast says to worship.
And if you don't worship, you will not
be able to buy or sell. Do you remember
the trucker strike in Canada? People
were giving gas cans to the truck
drivers, and they were having their bank
accounts frozen by the government. This
is too far. If people had cash only, you
can't turn that off. But when all things
go digital, by the click of a mouse, you
can be controlled. The signs of the
times are all around us. If you're
confused about the mark of the beast,
watch our video on the mark of the beast
and get ready because Jesus is coming
soon.